yeah put your hands up for detroit yeah
yeah Peters in a maneater brian is in
Tommy cage David cage da vikash with his
latest game de tois totally sold and you
play as some sort of you play as the
worst actor in heavy rain but as an
Android a police detective on blame is
robotic acting is true but you nice my
guy died on the second mission in heavy
rain I never got to play him again so
maybe that's well all I got and but yeah
this looked pretty interesting right
Peter yeah yeah i super love the idea of
androids and the question of
consciousness and identity and this
obviously is tackling that like full
bore and all of the various
possibilities I can play out seem very
interesting especially with the high
stakes in the scene they were showing I
was like there's no way like during this
demo they're going to show that girl
like get thrown off the roof no yeah
then it happened but I understand why
because they balanced it out so like
this is a game that seems very
interesting to me given the themes at
hand and the possibilities to explore
those like in great depth yeah like
massive blade runner vibes coming off at
obviously a detective story and Android
as well I'm in uh I was really impressed
by the pull back when it showed all the
different ways it could have gone yeah
would have done like that's really
compelling to me there's not like two
answers there's like a couple and the
acting stuff has gotten so good I'm also
kind of like I'm really relieved they
haven't used the celebrity this time cuz
there was something about beyond two
souls it was like I felt like it was
grabbing me out of it all the times like
Norman Reedus though we sure do love
that guy sure yeah that's so far in your
the direction it's like I don't take too
much uh yeah I'm the same as you i'm
like i feel like this happens every time
with every cage game I'm like I'm back
in but I'm back in but it was kind of
weird the things they were saying they
were like face dilemmas you gather
information me off the game like they're
like before I saw the branching
storylines stuff when they were putting
all this cheesy text into it to really
make it sound like like though it felt
like they were over selling it to me and
it felt right just a little bit cheesy
and I was like oh come on like really
like that's a bit too much like you know
this this kind of like things could have
been different you know like collect
information like well yeah collect
information that's
physiol EMAs every day alright but like
this kind of stuff I thought was
interesting like you know going back
through you know what happens in our are
you and backtracking I'm interested to
see how you actually play the game is
right whatever happens you can't go back
like or do you just restart the game and
playing like many different trees like
say I don't know until dawn yeah yeah I
would like a deadly cage game which is
actually replayable from start to finish
or its compelling me to do that because
as much as I love those other games
they're very much like 11 and done sort
of things yeah very instead let us know
what you think of Detroit in the
comments below